bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nos sur rt france le sénat a donc adopté
contre l'avis du gouvernement un
dispositif qui vise à aménager le régime
de responsabilité pénale des employeurs
locaux fonctionnaires qui seront amenés
à prendre des mesures pour permettre la
sortie du confinement quel regard est ce
que vous portez ce que selon c'est une
bonne chose
ben non c'est pas une bonne chose et on
revient quand même de loin puisque comme
vous l'avez dit le sénat avait adopté
une amnistie pas totale mais quand même
assez large puisque l empêcher de mettre
en cause la responsabilité lors on dit
souvent des mères mais comme vous l'avez
dit aussi c'est aussi de tous les
employeurs de tous les fonctionnaires
pendant toute la période d'état
d'urgence dont recommandé pour la
période à venir mais aussi pour la
période depuis le 23 mars
c'était donc une espèce de petit
amnisties partielles assez large qui
empêchait de mettre partiellement en
cause la responsabilité de toutes ces
personnes qui ont assez peur de ce qui
va se passer pendant le déconfinement
donc en particulier pour les
contaminations qui pourrait qui pourrait
arriver dans le public en marche avait
essayé d'apporter à 140 députés
l'avaient proposé avec aurore bergé
soutenu en cela par le medef et au
parlement en tout cas au niveau du sénat
et les républicains qui avaient mis en
place cette amnistie partielle
il s'est passé quelque chose de très
intéressant c'est que le gouvernement
finalement essayé de faire un peu
machine arrière
mais au sénat quand il a proposé de
supprimer cet amendement des
républicains il a eu zéro sénateurs pour
le soutenir et 327 sénateurs ont voté
pour le maintien de facto de cette
amnistie
alors par chance comme vous l'avez dit
aussi ça a changé hier en commission des
lois à l'assemblée
enfin faudra voir si cet après midi ils
ne risquent pas de ressurgir une
un petit amendement de dernière minute
pour emploi mais tu peux être très
vigilants le dispositif tel qu'il a donc
été adopté par le sénat stipule que
pendant l'état d'urgence sanitaire nul
ne peut voir sa responsabilité pénale
engagée pour des contaminations par le
coran navires us sauf en cas d'
intention délibérée imprudence ou
négligence en gros un responsable mais
pas coupable quel message risquerait
selon vous d'être envoyés si le
dispositif était appliqué quel est le
dispositif qui votait l'assemblée comme
extrêmement allégées ne restait que ça
change pas grand chose en tout cas dans
ce qui est proposé là en tout cas dans
la version précédente
oui c'était c'était une amnistie
partielle
assez assez large il faut dire que tous
les décideurs ont extrêmement peur parce
que le nombre de fautes qui ont été
commises que saïda évidemment n'est pas
constitué de masquer un des stocks de
masques mais aussi dire aux gens de ne
surtout pas en mettre alors que
évidemment bassin avait mis ça aurait au
moins diminuer un petit peu l'épidémie
cette nature à engager la responsabilité
beaucoup de personne et avec les
opérations de déconfinement en
particulier la réouverture des écoles
il ya un risque assez important peut
évidemment de nombreux procès ait lieu à
l'avenir parce qu'il fait peur à
beaucoup d'élus et beaucoup beaucoup
d'employeurs faut bien voir que les
enfants sont quand même aussi des
vecteurs de contamination se disputer
pour savoir jusqu'où en tout cas ça en
fait partie et ce matin sur notre site
les crises on a montré une étude sur
plus de 2000 enfants chinois montré que
pendant la moitié des cas il y avait des
formes on voit modéré d'atteinte
pulmonaire et dans 5 à 10 % des cas des
formes sévères critiques donc aussi les
enfants sont potentiellement un un peu
en danger et en tout cas pas vos tirs 1
et virus et la mezzo et de la vidéo
c'est quand même très dangereux pour les
enfants de moins de un an
qu'est ce qui est prévu aujourd'hui
compter protège les
les décideurs les maires notamment
qu'est ce qui est prévu aujourd'hui ce
qu'il ya un vide juridique qui explique
qui expliquerait la nécessité veut du de
la part des élus locaux
dans ce contexte très particulier qu'est
ce qui peut les protéger jusque là
aujourd'hui a aucun vide juridique elle
a la responsabilité des maires eux mêmes
est relativement bien l'encadrer
depuis les années 2000 un pain aux noix
qui limitent à des cas extrêmement
précis la possibilité de les mettre en
cause donc on se demande même pourquoi
il ya tous ces taux évoluent soit disant
pour protéger les moeurs mais on voit
très bien que l'idée a été de dire oh
bah on va essayer de faire une une
protection des mères et au final on se
retrouve à avoir une espèce d'aministie
non seulement des mers mois ci dans 100
des élus des ministres de l'ensemble des
hauts fonctionnaires donc toutes les
hauts fonctionnaires qui ont peu les
décisions de santé publique sont
concernés par ce projet qu'il y avait en
tout cas qui a été voté au sénat mais
aussi les employeurs donc voilà on voit
qu'on est créée après l'axé largement
dépassé la responsabilité du maire dans
la verdure d'une école qui est quand
même extrêmement encadré il peu probable
que le maire puisse être attaqué en
revanche des employeurs qui ne vont pas
prendre toutes les mesures pour protéger
les salariés
les hauts fonctionnaires qui seront pas
achetés les masques et les ministres et
qui ont raconté n'importe quoi là on va
très bien que la responsabilité ne peut
être engagée merci beaucoup pour votre
regard olivier à bruyères animateur et
créateur du site
les crises point fr et après le sénat
c'est donc à l'assemblée nationale aux
députés de se prononcer sur cet
amendement et plus généralement sur la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire on suivra évidemment ça avec
attention cet après midi